la question fondamentale c'est celle
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est le travail
ces questions je travaille moi même
depuis six ans après avoir étudié des
travaux ou des mighty ducks voorn qui
ont été très largement commentée j'avais
moi même écrit un livre dessus et en
particulier ceux de ce rapport des
mighty qui montrait que 147 % des
emplois aux etats-unis pourrait être
automatisés parce que les gens qui les
font sont prolétarisés mais il a dit
aussi qu'ils avaient peut-être un peu
exagéré en arrivant à 47%
ça pouvait être que dix noms le croyais
pas non non ce qu ils ont été mal
interprétés ils n'ont jamais dit que 47%
des enfants allaient disparaître nous
avait dit ça on n'a jamais dit ça ça
c'est fait désormais et moi non plus
j'ai jamais dit qu'il disait ça
aujourd'hui qu'il disait que 47 %
d'emplois sont automatisables veut pas
dire qu'ils vont l'être
voilà aujourd'hui le scd e dernier rapt
en hausse de 14 % des emplois existants
dans le monde de l' ocde dans tous les
pays le c'est devant disparaître
c'est quand même que c'est considérable
et c'est l' ocde qui pendant longtemps a
d'abord dit 5% n'a pas 7 % 10 %
maintenance et 14
donc voilà il ya une tendance très forte
de toute façon il suffit de regarder
autour de l'automatisation ça va
l'automatisation fait disparaître des
emplois et ça pose évidemment des
problèmes de solvabilité économique
parce que moi il ya l'employé moyen
pouvoir d'achat - pouvoir d'achat moyen
de vente et c'est donc le système ne
peut que s'effondrer et l'effondrement
il viendra peut-être d'abord de cela six
lits à un effondrement au sens voilà une
rupture brutale
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait sûr mais
c'est très probable c'est très probable
mais ce n'est pas tout à fait sur moi je
me bats pour éviter ça
[Musique]